béret de ne pas se maquiller se sentir
bien dans leur peau comme voilà bientôt
les concours de beauté on va dire la
plus moche c'est à peu près ce qu'on va
faire maintenant le maquillage et les
chirurgies on enlève tout il faut être
beau peu importe comment voilà c'est
ridicule sinon nous venons ici aussi
sans maquillage on va 30 pierre bodein
comme raymond
met tout le monde à égalité aussi oui
pas se maquiller le fait d'arriver comme
comme tizi comme vous êtes ça peut être
ça peut mettre tout le monde en créant
la patrie des pense que c'est le
maquillage qui le différencie j'attends
maintenant bien alors que oui et a bien
sûr que oui il vient semble alors je les
joueurs au maillot cet été alors il n'y
a pas que ça qui vous différencie il est
magnifique
moi je pense qu'on fait parler des
sommes clairement hypocrite parce que je
pense que vous êtes bien content quand
les femmes se pouponner se font belles
pour vous déjà si une meuf un soir à la
rive au restaurant et qu'elle ait des
maquillée habillée en pyjama je pense
pas que ça va te plaire en toute
honnêteté en handi peau contrôlant
cependant je suis désolé j'ai pas
attirés par les meufs des matinées dit
pas trop rêver on ne dit pas qu une
femme maquillée on dit pas qu une femme
à qui et c'est pas joli aussi